[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I was you know into water goddess energy
and something that made me feel like I
was floating look at all this stuff
is this dress a little bit of a shout
out to Maryland it is yes it is and I
feel like it's kind of like the
silhouette of
Marilyn man
maybe it weren't today and with a little
bit of crystals and that look like rose
petals at the bottom on a silk organza
gown took 1 000 hours to make the
embroidery alone 650 hours Jamie Lee
Curtis's dress on the other hand so my
Dolce Gabbana dress which came to me two
days ago I decided to dress like an
Oscar in case I don't win one
the biggest trend on the champagne
carpet stars coming in white hot but
riri's Lift Me Up co-writer Tim's legit
stole the show or should we say locked
it for everyone seated behind her how do
you get around with that how have you
moved how did you get here I got here by
being carried well Olivia Wilde and
Halle Berry got where they needed to be
standing up in Sprinter vans what are
those Roses made of holly
explain the inspiration behind the peach
well this is ballet pink uh this flower
represents my daughters
Dwayne Johnson's look was custom Dolce
and Gabbana but looks ripped from the
runway Lady Gaga's gown was worn by Gigi
Hadid at the Versace fashion show just
three days before Cara Della means
elisab gave us Angelina Jolie 2012 Oscar
Vibes hello right leg while Zoe
Saldana's lingerie themed look is Fendi
[Music]
oh my God he tripped me but things got a
little hairy for cocaine bear director
Elizabeth Banks who ended up ditching
her heels after that on stage stumble
[Applause]
[Music]
leading off Oscar's fashion Transformers
Mindy Kaling on the carpet she had this
white column dress with cutouts then
switched to a black version of the same
gown to present then she opted for a
metallic sequins as she hit the Vanity
Fair party with her ex-office boyfriend
BJ Novak
other Quick Change artists Florence Pew
Eva Longoria bastong Ana de armas and
Kate Hudson
how did you settle on this for the after
party you know
in them all with four outfits in one
night first this mocha leather Alaya
dress on stage it was a black bra
embellished with a curtain of crystals
cascading over her baby belly
look three was mint green tummy on
display then this Bejeweled bikini top
at Beyonce and Jay-Z's after party but
the night's Most Daring dresses
you rocking it
Olivia's secret about this look
twins are on this it is so
it's already falling off because you
know I'm a busy person
Lisa Rena was bold in black and white
Jean-Paul Gaultier and how about this
last minute Couture confession from her
former Housewives co-star Kyle Richards
didn't have a dress or hair makeup
people so I did it myself and I borrowed
my daughters I just took it from her
closet
[Music]
thank you